The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right, it
is time to get started.
Thanks for coming for
this cold and rainy
Wednesday before Thanksgiving.
Today we're supposed to talk
about the radial equation.
That's our main subject today.
We discussed last
time the states
of angular momentum from
the abstract viewpoint,
and now we make contact with
some important problems,
and differential equations,
and things like that.
And there's a few concepts
I want to emphasize today.
And basically, the
main concept is
that I want you to just become
familiar with what we would
call the diagram, the key
diagram for the states
of a theory, of a particle in
a three dimensional potential.
I think you have to have a good
understanding of what it looks,
and what is special
about it, and when
it shows particular properties.
So to begin with, I'll
have to do a little aside
on a object that is
covered in many courses.
I don't know to what
that it's covered,
but it's the subject
of spherical harmonics.
So we'll talk about spherical
harmonics for about 15 minutes.
And then we'll do
the radial equation.
And for the radial equation,
after we discuss it,
we'll do three examples.
And that will be the
end of today's lecture.
Next time, as you come back
from the holiday next week,
we are doing the addition of
angular momentum basically.
And then the last week,
more examples and a few more
things for emphasis to
understand it all well.
All right, so in terms
of spherical harmonics,
I wanted to emphasize that
our algebraic analysis led
to states that we
called jm, but today I
will call lm, because they
will refer to orbital angular
momentum.
And as you've seen in
one of your problems,
orbital angular
momentum has to do
with values of j,
which are integers.
So half integers values of j
cannot be realized for orbital
angular momentum.
It's a very interesting thing.
So spin states don't have wave
functions in the usual way.
It's only states of
integer angular momentum
that have wave functions.
And those are the
spherical harmonics.
So I will talk about
lm, and l, as usual,
will go from 0 to infinity.
And m goes from l to minus l.
And you had these states, and
we said that algebraically you
would have L squared equals h
squared l times l plus 1 lm.
And Lz lm equal hm lm.
Now basically, the
spherical harmonics
are going to be wave
functions for these states.
And the way we
can approach it is
that we did a little bit of work
already with constructing the l
squared operator.
And in last lecture we derived,
starting from the fact that L
is r cross p and using
x,y, and z, px, py, pz,
and passing through spherical
coordinates that L squared is
the operator minus h squared 1
over sine theta d d theta sine
theta d d theta again plus
1 over sine squared theta d
second d phi squared.
And we didn't do it,
but Lz, which you know
is h bar over i x d dy
minus y d dx can also
be translated into
angular variables.
And it has a very simple form.
Also purely angular.
And you can interpret it Lz is
rotations around the z-axis,
so they change phi.
So it will not
surprise you, if you
do this exercise, that
this is h over i d d phi.
And you should really check it.
There's another one that
is a bit more laborious.
L plus minus, remember,
is Lx plus minus i Lz.
We have a big attendance today.
Is equal to-- more people.
h bar e to the plus minus i phi
i cosine theta over sine theta
d d phi plus minus d d theta.
And that takes a bit of algebra.
You could do it.
It's done in many books.
It's probably there
in Griffith's.
And these are the
representations
of these operators as
differential operators that
act and function
on theta and phi
and don't care about radius.
So in mathematical physics,
people study these things
and invent these things
called spherical harmonics
Ylm's of theta and phi.
And the way you
could see their done
is in fact, such that
this L squared viewed
as this operator, differential
operator, acting on Ylm
is indeed equal to h squared
l times l plus 1 Ylm.
And Lz thought also as a
differential operator, the one
that we've written there.
On the Ylm is h bar m Ylm.
So they are constructed
in this way,
satisfying these equations.
These are important equations
in mathematical physics,
and these functions
were invented
to satisfy those equations.
Well, these are the properties
of those states over there.
So we can think
of these functions
as the wave functions
associated with those states.
So that's interpretation that
is natural in quantum mechanics.
And we want to think
of them like that.
We want to think of the Ylm's
as the wave functions associated
to the states lm.
So lm.
And here you would put a
position state theta phi.
This is analogous to the
thing that we usually
call the wave function being a
position state times the state
side.
So we want to think of
the Ylm's in this way
as pretty much the wave
functions associated
to those states.
Now there is a little bit of
identities that come once you
accept that this is what
you think of the Ylm's.
And then the compatibility
of these equations.
Top here with these ones makes
in this identification natural.
Now in order to manipulate
and learn things
about those spherical
harmonics the way
we do things in
quantum mechanics,
we think of the
completeness relation.
If we have d cube x x x, this
is a completeness relation
for position states.
And I want to derive or
suggest a completeness relation
for these theta phi states.
For that, I would
pass this integral
to do it in spherical
coordinates.
So I would do dr rd
theta r sine theta d phi.
And I would put r theta
phi position states
for these things.
And position states r theta phi.
Still being equal to 1.
And we can try to
split this thing.
It's natural for us to
think of just theta phi,
because these wave functions
have nothing to do with r,
so I will simply do
the integrals this way.
d theta sine theta d phi.
And think just like a
position state in x, y, z.
It's a position state in x,
in y, and in z multiplied.
We'll just split these
things without trying
to be too rigorous about it.
Theta and phi like this.
And you would have the integral
dr r squared r r equal 1.
And at this point,
I want to think
of this as the natural way of
setting a completeness relation
for theta and phi.
And this doesn't
talk to this one,
so I will think of this that
in the space of theta and phi,
objects that just
depend on theta and phi,
this acts as a complete thing.
And if objects depend
also in r, this
will act as a complete thing.
So I will-- I don't know.
Maybe the right way
to say is postulate
that we'll have a completeness
relation of this form.
d theta sine theta d phi
theta phi theta phi equals 1.
And then with this we can
do all kinds of things.
First, this integral
is better written.
This integral really represents
0 to pi d theta sine theta 0
to 2 pi d phi.
Now this is minus
d cosine theta.
And when theta is equal
to 0, cosine theta
is 1 to minus 1 integral
d phi 0 to 2 pi.
So this integral, really
d theta sine theta d
phi this is really the
integral from minus 1 to 1.
Change that order of d cos theta
integral d phi from 0 to 2 pi.
And this is called the
integral over solid angle.
That's a definition.
So we could write the
completeness relation
in the space theta phi as
integral over solid angle theta
phi theta phi equals 1.
Then the key property of
the spherical harmonics,
or the lm states, is
that they are orthogonal.
So delta l, l prime,
delta m, m prime.
So the orthogonality
are of this state
is guaranteed because
Hermitian operators,
different eigenvalues,
they have to be orthogonal.
Eigenstates of Hermitian.
Operators with
different eigenvalues.
Here, you introduce a complete
set of states of theta phi.
So you put l prime m prime
theta phi theta phi lm.
And this is the integral over
solid angle of Yl prime m
prime of theta phi star.
This is in the wrong position.
And here Ylm of theta
phi being equal delta l
l prime delta m m prime.
So this is orthogonality
of the spherical harmonics.
And this is pretty
much all we need.
Now there's the standard ways
of constructing these things
from the quantum mechanical
sort of intuition.
Basically, you can
try to first build
Yll, which corresponds
to the state ll.
Now the kind of
differential equations
this Yll satisfies
are kind of simple.
But in particular,
the most important one
is that L plus kills this state.
So basically you
use the condition
that L plus kills this
state to find a differential
equation for this, which
can be solved easily.
Not a hard
differential equation.
Then you find Yll.
And then you can find Yll
minus 1 and all the other ones
by applying the
operator L minus.
The lowering operator of m.
So in principle, if you
have enough patience,
you can calculate all the
spherical harmonics that way.
There's no obstruction.
But the form is a
little messy, and if you
want to find the normalizations
so that these things work out
correctly, well, it takes some
work at the end of the day.
So we're not going
to do that here.
We'll just leave it at
that, and if we ever
need some special harmonics,
we'll just hold the answers.
And they are in most textbooks.
So if you do need
them, well, you'll
have to do with
complicated normalizations.
So that's really all I wanted to
say about spherical harmonics,
and we can turn then to
the real subject, which
is the radial equation.
So the radial equation.
So we have a Hamiltonian
H equals p squared vector
over 2m plus v of r.
And we've seen that
this is equal to h over
2m 1 over r d second dr
squared r plus 1 over 2mr
squared L squared plus v of r.
So this is what we're
trying to solve.
And the way we
attempt to solve this
is by separation of variables.
So we'll try to write the wave
function, psi, characterized
by three things.
Its energy, the value of
l, and the value of m.
And it's a function of
position, because we're
trying to solve H
psi equal E psi.
And that's the energy
that we want to consider.
So I will write here to begin
with something that will not
turn out to be exactly
right, but it's
important to do
it first this way.
A function of art r that
has labels E, l, and m.
Because it certainly could
depend on E, could depend on l,
and could depend on m,
that radial function.
And then the angular
function will
be the Ylm's of theta and phi.
So this is the [INAUDIBLE]
sets for the equation.
If we have that, we can plug
into the Schrodinger equation,
and see what we get.
Well, this operator
will act on this f.
This will have the
operator L squared,
but L squared over Ylm,
you know what it is.
And v of r is multiplicative,
so it's no big problem.
So what do we have?
We have minus h squared
over 2m 1 over r.
Now I can talk
normal derivatives.
d r squared r times fElm
plus 1 over 2mr squared.
And now have L squared
acting on this,
but L squared acting on the
Ylm is just this factor.
So we have h squared l times
l plus 1 times the fElm.
Now I didn't put the
Ylm in the first term
because I'm going to
cancel it throughout.
So we have this term here plus
v of r fElm equals E fElm.
That is substituting into the
equation h psi equal E psi.
So first term here.
Second term, it acted on
the spherical harmonic.
v of r is multiplicative.
E on that.
But then what you
see immediately
is that this differential
equation doesn't depend on m.
It was L squared, but no
Lz in the Hamiltonian.
So no m dependent.
So actually we
were overly proven
in thinking that f
was a function of m.
What we really have
is that psi Elm
is equal to a function of E
and l or r Ylm of theta phi.
And then the
differential equation
is minus h squared over 2m.
Let's multiply all by r.
d second dr squared of r fEl.
Plus look here.
The r that I'm multiplying
is going to go into the f.
Here it's going
to go into the f.
It's an overall thing.
But here we keep h
squared l times l
plus 1 over 2mr squared rfEl
plus v of r fEl rfEl equal
e times rfEl.
So what you see here is that
this function is quite natural.
So it suggests the
definition of uEl to be rfEl.
So that the differential
equation now finally becomes
minus h squared over 2m d
second dr squared of uEl plus
there's the u here, the u
here, and this potential
that has two terms.
So this will be v of
r plus h squared l
times l plus 1 over 2mr
squared uEl equals E times eEl.
And this is the famous
radial equation.
It's an equation for you.
And here, this whole
thing is sometimes
called the effective potential.
So look what we've got.
This f, if you wish here,
is now of the form uEl
of r Ylm over r theta phi.
f is u over r.
So this is the way we've
written the solution,
and u satisfies this equation,
which is a one dimensional
Schrodinger equation
for the radius r.
One dimensional equation
with an effective potential
that depends on L.
So actually the first
thing you have to notice
is that the central
potential problem
has turned into an
infinite collection of one
dimensional problems.
One for each value of l.
For different values of l, you
have a different potential.
Now they're not
all that different.
They have different
intensity of this term.
For l equals 0, well
you have some solutions.
And for l equal 1, the answer
could be quite different.
For l equal 2, still different.
And you have to solve
an infinite number
of one dimensional problems.
That's what the Schrodinger
equation has turned into.
So we filled all
these blackboards.
Let's see, are there questions?
Anything so far?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You might
get to this later,
but what does it mean
in our wave equations,
in our wave function there,
psi of Elm is equal to fEl,
and the spherical harmonic
of that one mean that one has
an independence and
the other doesn't.
Can they be separated
on the basis of m?
PROFESSOR: So it is just a fact
that the radial solution is
independent of n, so it's
an important property.
n is fairly simple.
The various state, the
states with angular momentum
l, but different m's just differ
in their angular dependence,
not in the radial dependence.
And practically,
it means that you
have an infinite set of one
dimensional problems labeled
by l, and not labeled by m,
which conceivably could have
happened, but it doesn't happen.
So just a major simplicity.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does the
radial equation
have all the same properties as
a one dimensional Schrodinger
equation?
Or does the divergence in
the effect [INAUDIBLE] 0
change that?
PROFESSOR: Well,
it changes things,
but the most serious
change is the fact
that, in one
dimensional problems,
x goes from minus
infinity to infinity.
And here it goes
from 0 to infinity,
so we need to worry
about what happens at 0.
Basically that's the
main complication.
One dimensional potential,
but it really just
can't go below 0.
r is a radial variable,
and we can't forget that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The potential v of r
will depend on whatever problem
you're solving, right?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Could you find
the v of r [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well
that doesn't quite
make sense as a Hamiltonian.
You see, if you
have a v of r, it's
something that is supposed to
be v of r for any wave function.
That's the definition.
So it can depend
on some parameter,
but that parameter cannot be
the l of the particular wave
function.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] or
something that would interact
with the--
PROFESSOR: If you
have magnetic fields,
things change, because
then you can split levels
with respect to m.
Break degeneracies and
things change indeed.
We'll take care of those by
using perturbation theory
mostly.
Use this solution and
then perturbation theory.
OK, so let's proceed
a little more on this.
So the first thing that we
want to talk a little about
is the normalization and
some boundary conditions,
because otherwise
we can't really
understand what's going on.
And happily the discussion
is not that complicated.
So we want to normalize.
So what do we want?
Integral d cube x psi Elm
of x squared equals 1.
So clearly we want to go
into angular variables.
So again, this is r squared
dr integral d solid angle,
r squared Er.
And this thing is now uEl
squared absolute value
over r squared.
Look at the right
most blackboard.
uEl of r, I must square it
because the wave function
is squared.
Over r squared.
And then I have Ylm star of
theta phi Ylm of theta phi.
And if this is supposed
to be normalized,
this is supposed
to be the number 1.
Well happily, this
part, this is why
we needed to talk a little
about spherical harmonics.
This integral is 1, because
it corresponds precisely
to l equal l prime
m equal m prime.
And look how lucky
or nice this is.
r squared cancels
with r squared,
so the final condition
is the integral from 0
to infinity dr uEl of r
squared is equal to 1,
which shows that
kind of the u really
plays a role for wave
function and a line.
And even though it was
a little complicated,
there was the r here,
and angular dependence,
and everything, a
good wave function
is one that is just
think of psi as being u.
A one dimensional wave
function psi being u,
and if you can integrate
it square, you've got it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Because I
had to square this,
so there was u over r.
AUDIENCE: But
that's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
That parenthesis is a remnant.
I tried to erase it a little.
It's not squared anymore.
The square is on the
absolute value is r squared.
So this is good news
for our interpretation.
So now before I discuss the
peculiarities of the boundary
conditions, I want to
introduce really the main point
that we're going to
illustrate in this lecture.
This is the thing that
should remain in your heads.
It's a picture, but
it's an important one.
When you want to
organize the spectrum,
you'll draw the
following diagram.
Energy is here and l here.
And it's a funny
kind of diagram.
It's not like a curve or a plot.
It's like a histogram or
kind of thing like that.
So what will happen is that you
have a one dimensional problem.
If these potentials are normal,
there will be bound states.
And let's consider the
case of bound states
for the purposes of this
graph, just bound states.
Now you look at
this, and you say OK,
what am I supposed to do?
I'm going to have states
for all values of l,
and m, and probably
some energies.
So m doesn't affect
the radial equation.
That's very important.
But l does, so I have
a different problem
to solve for different l.
So I will make my histogram
here and put here l
equals 0 at this region.
l equals 1, l equals 2,
l equals 3, and go on.
Now suppose I fix an l.
l is fixed.
Now it's a Schrodinger equation
for a one dimensional problem.
You would expect that if the
potential suitably grows, which
is a typical case,
E will be quantized.
And there will not
be degeneracies,
because the bound state
spectrum in one dimension
is not degenerate.
So I should expect
that for each l there
are going to be energy values
that are going to appear.
So for l equals 0, I expect that
there will be some energy here
for which I've got a state.
And that line means
I got a state.
And there's some energy here
that could be called E1,
0 is the first energy that
is allowed with l equals 0.
Then there will be
another one here maybe.
E-- I'll write it down-- 2,0.
So basically I'm labeling the
energies with En,l which means
the first solution
with l equals 0,
the second solution
the third solution E 3,0.
Then you come to l
equals 1, and you
must solve the equation again.
And then for l equal 1, there
will be the lowest energy,
the ground state energy of
the l equal 1 potential,
and then higher and higher.
Since the l equal 1
potential is higher
than the l equals 0
potential, it's higher up.
The energies should
be higher up,
at least the first
one should be.
And therefore the
first one could
be a little higher than this,
or maybe by some accident
it just fits here, or
maybe it should fit here.
Well, we don't know
but know, but there's
no obvious reason why it
should, so I'll put it here.
l equals 1.
And this would be E1,1.
The first state with l equals 1.
Then here it could be E2,1.
The second state with l
equal 1 and higher up.
And then for l equal-- my
diagram is a little too big.
E1,1.
E2,1.
And then you have states here,
so maybe this one, l equals 2,
I don't know where it goes.
It just has to be higher than
this one, so I'll put it here.
And this will be E1,2.
Maybe there's an E2,2.
And here an E1,3.
But this is the answer
to your problem.
That's the energy levels
of a central potential.
So it's a good,
nice little diagram
in which you put the states,
you put the little line wherever
you find the state.
And for l equals 0,
you have those states.
Now because there's no
degeneracies in the bound
states of a one
dimensional potential,
I don't have two lines here
that coincide, because there's
no two states with
the same energy here.
It's just one state.
And this one here.
I cannot have two things there.
That's pretty important to.
So you have a list
of states here.
And just one state here, one
state, but as you can see,
you're probably are catching
me in a little wrong play
of words, because I say
there's one state here.
Yes, it's one state,
because it's l equals 0.
One state, one state.
But this state,
which is one single--
this should be called one
single l equal 1 multiplet.
So this is not really one
state at the end of the day.
It's one state of the one
dimensional radial equation,
but you know that l
equals 1 comes accompanied
with three values of m.
So there's three states
that are degenerate,
because they have
the same energy.
The energy doesn't depend on l.
So this thing is an
l equal 1 multiplet,
which means really three states.
And this is three states.
And this is 1 l equal
2 multiplet, which
has possibility of m equals
2, 1, 0 minus 1 and minus 2.
So in this state is just
one l equal 2 multiplet,
but it really means five states
of the central potential.
Five degenerate
states, because the m
doesn't change the energy.
And this is five states.
And this is seven states.
One l equal 3 multiplet,
which contains seven states.
OK, so questions?
This is the most
important graph.
If you have that
picture in your head,
then you can
understand really where
you're going with any potential.
Any confusion here
above the notation?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So normally
when we think about a one
dimensional problem, we say
that there's no degeneracy.
Not really.
No multiple degeneracy,
so should we
think of the radial equation as
having copies for each m value
and each having the
same eigenvalue?
PROFESSOR: I don't
think it's necessary.
You see, you've got your uEl.
And you have here you solutions.
Once the uEl is
good, you're supposed
to be able to put any Ylm.
So put l, and now the m's that
are allowed are solutions.
You're solving the problem.
So think of a master radial
function as good for a fixed l,
and therefore it works
for all values of m.
But don't try to think of
many copies of this equation.
I don't think it would help you.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sorry to ask,
but if you could just
review how is degeneracy
built one more time?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Remember last time we
were talking about,
for example, what is a
j equal to multiplet.
Well, these were a collection
of states jm with j
equals 2 an m sum value.
And they are all obtained by
acting with angular momentum
operators in each other.
And there are five states.
The 2,2, the 2,1, the 2,0, the
2, minus 1, and the 2, minus 2.
And all these
states are obtained
by acting with, say, lowering
operators l minus and this.
Now all these angular
momentum operators,
all of the Li's commute
with the Hamiltonian.
Therefore all of
these states are
obtained by acting with Li
must have the same energy.
That's why we say that
this comes in a multiplet.
So when you get j-- in this case
we'll call it l-- l equals 2.
You get five states.
They correspond to the
various values of m.
So when you did that
radial equation that
has a solution for
l equals 2, you're
getting the full multiplet.
You're getting five states.
1 l equal 2 multiplet.
That's why one line here.
That is equivalent
to five states.
OK, so that diagram, of course,
is really quite important.
So now we want to understand
the boundary conditions.
So we have here this.
So this probably
shouldn't erase yet.
Let's do the
boundary conditions.
So behavior here
at r equals to 0.
At r going to 0.
The first claim is that
surprisingly, you would think,
well, normalization is king.
If it's normalized, it's good.
So just any number.
Just don't let it diverge
near 0, and that will be OK.
But it turns out
that that's not true.
It's not right.
And you need the limit as r goes
to 0 of uEl of r be equal to 0.
And we'll take this and
explore the simplest case.
That is corresponds to
saying what if the limit of r
goes to 0 or uEl of
r was a constant?
What goes wrong?
Certainly normalization
doesn't go wrong.
It can be a constant.
u could be like that, and
it would be normalized,
and that doesn't go wrong.
So let's look at
the wave function.
What happens with this?
I actually will
take for simplicity,
because we'll analyze it later,
the example of l equals 0.
So let's put even 0.
l equals 0.
Well, suppose you look
at the wave function now,
and how does it look?
Psi of E0-- if l is equal
to 0, m must be equal to 0--
would be this u over
r times a constant.
So a constant, because
y 0, 0 is a constant.
And then you uE0 of r over r.
So when r approaches 0, psi
goes like c prime over r,
some other constant over r.
So I'm doing
something very simple.
I'm saying if uE0 is approaching
the constant at the origin,
if it's uE0, well, this is
a constant because it's 0,0.
So this is going to constant.
So at the end of the
day, the wave function
looks like 1 over r.
But this is impossible, because
the Schrodinger equation H
psi has minus h squared over 2m
Laplacian on psi plus dot dot
dot.
And the up Laplacian of 1 over
r is minus 4 pi times a delta
function at x equals 0.
So this means that the
Schrodinger equation,
you think oh I put
psi equals c over r.
Well, if you calculate the
Laplacian, it seems to be 0.
But if you're more careful,
as you know for [? emm ?]
the Laplacian of 1 over r is
minus 4 pi times the delta
function.
So in the Schrodinger
equation, the kinetic term
produces a delta function.
There's no reason
to believe there's
a delta function
in the potential.
We'll not try such
crazy potentials.
A delta function in a one
dimensional potential,
you've got the solution.
A delta function in a
three dimensional potential
is absolutely crazy.
It has infinite number
of bound states,
and they just go
all the way down
to energies of minus infinity.
It's a very horrendous
thing, a delta function
in three dimensions,
for quantum mechanics.
So this thing, there's no delta
function in the potential.
And you've got a delta
function from the kinetic term.
You're not going to
be able to cancel it.
This is not a solution.
So you really cannot
approach a constant there.
It's quite bad.
So the wave functions
will have to vanish,
and we can prove that, or at
least under some circumstances
prove it.
And as all these
things are, they all
depend on how crazy
potentials you want to accept.
So we should say something.
So I'll say something
about these potentials,
and we'll prove a result.
So my statement will be the
centrifugal barrier, which
is a name for this
part of the potential,
dominates as r goes to 0.
If this doesn't happen,
all bets are off.
So let's assume that v of
r, maybe it's 1 over r,
but it's not worse
than 1 over r squared.
It's 1 over r
cubed, for example,
or something like that.
You would have to
analyze it from scratch
if it would be that bad.
But I will assume that the
centrifugal barrier dominates.
And then look at the
differential equation.
Well, what differential
equation do I have?
Well, I have this and this.
This thing is less
important than that,
and this is also less
important, because this is u
divided by r squared.
And here is just u.
So this is certainly
less important than that,
and this is less
important than that,
and if I want to have
some variation of u,
or understand how it
varies, I must keep this.
So at this order, I should
keep just the kinetic term
h squared over 2m d
second dr squared u of El.
And h squared l times l
plus 1 over 2 mr squared.
And I will try to cancel these
two to explore how the wave
function looks near or equal 0.
These are the two most important
terms of the differential
equation, so I have the
right to keep those, and try
to balance them out to leading
order, and see what I get.
So all the h squared
over 2m's go away.
So this is equivalent to
d second uEl dr squared is
equal to l times l plus
1 uEl over r squared.
And this is solved
by a power uEl.
You can try r to the
s, some number s.
And then this thing gives
you s times s minus 1.
Taking two derivatives is
equal to l times l plus 1.
As you take two derivatives,
you lose two powers of r,
so it will work out.
And from here, you see
that the possible solutions
are s equals l plus 1.
And s equals 2 minus l.
So this corresponds
to a uEl that
goes like r to the
l plus 1, or a uEl
that goes like 1
over r to the l.
This Is far too singular.
For l equals 0, we argued
that the wave function
should go like a constant.
I'm sorry, cannot
go like a constant.
Must vanish.
This is not possible.
It's not a solution.
It must vanish.
For l equals 0, uE0 goes
like r and vanishes.
So that's consistent,
and this is good.
For l equals 0, this would
be like a constant as well
and would be fine.
But for l equals 1
already, this is 1 over r,
and this is not normalizable.
So this time this is not
normalizable for l greater
or equal than one.
So this is the answer
[INAUDIBLE] this assumption,
which is a very
reasonable assumption.
But if you don't have
that you have to beware.
OK, this is our
condition for u there.
And so uEl goes like
this as r goes to 0.
It would be the whole answer.
So f, if you care about f still,
which is what appears here,
goes like u divided by r.
So fEl goes like cr to the l.
And when l is equal to 0,
f behaves like a constant.
u vanishes for l
equal to 0, but f
goes like a
constant, which means
that if you take 0
orbital angular momentum,
you may have some
probability of finding
the particle at the origin,
because this f behaves
like a constant for l equals 0.
On the other hand,
for any higher l,
f will also vanish
at the origin.
And that is intuitively said
that the centrifugal barrier
prevents the particle
from reaching the origin.
There's a barrier,
a potential barrier.
This potential is
1 over r squared.
Doesn't let you go to
close to the origin.
But that potential
disappears for l equals 0,
and therefore the particle
can reach the origin.
But only for l equals 0
it can reach the origin.
OK, one more thing.
Behavior near infinity
is of interest as well.
So what happens for
r goes to infinity?
Well, for r goes to
infinity, you also
have to be a little
careful what you assume.
I wish I could tell you it's
always like this, but it's not.
It's rich in all
kinds of problems.
So there's two
cases where there's
an analysis that is simple.
Suppose v of r is equal to 0
for r greater than some r0.
Or r times v of f goes to
0 as r goes to infinity.
Two possibilities.
The potential is plane
0 after some distance.
Or the potential
multiplied by r goes to 0
as r goes to infinity.
And you would say, look, you've
missed the most important case.
The hydrogen atom, the
potential is 1 over r.
r times v of r doesn't go to 0.
And indeed, what I'm
going to write here
doesn't quite apply to the wave
functions of the hydrogen atom.
They're a little unusual.
The potential of the hydrogen
atom is felt quite far away.
So never the less, if you
have those conditions,
we can ignore the potential
as we go far away.
And we'll consider the
following situation.
Look that the centrifugal
barrier satisfies this as well.
So the full effective
potential satisfies.
If v of r satisfies
that, r times 1
over r squared of effective
potential also satisfies that.
So we can ignore
all the potential,
and we're left
ignore the effective.
And therefore we're left
with minus h squared
over 2m d second uEl dr
squared is equal to EuEl.
And that's a very
trivial equation.
Yes, Matt?
AUDIENCE: When you
say v of r goes
to 0 for r greater
than [INAUDIBLE] 0.
Are you effectively
[INAUDIBLE] the potential?
PROFESSOR: Right, there may
be some potentials like this.
A potential that is like that.
An attractive potential, and it
vanishes after some distance.
Or a repulsive potential that
AUDIENCE: But say the potential
was a [INAUDIBLE] potential.
Are you just approximating it
to 0 after it's [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, if I'm in
the [INAUDIBLE] potential,
unfortunately I'm
neither here nor here,
so this doesn't apply.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
potential is an exception.
The solutions are
a little more--
AUDIENCE: The conditions
you're saying. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So these
are conditions
that allow me to say something.
If they're not
satisfied, I sort of
have to analyze
them case by case.
That's the price we have to pay.
It's a little more complicated
than you would think naively.
Now here, it's interesting to
consider two possibilities.
The case when E is less
than 0, or the case when
E is greater than 0.
So scattering solutions
or bound state solutions.
For these ones, if the
energy is less than 0
and there's no potential, you're
in the forbidden zone far away,
so you must have a
decaying exponential.
El goes like exponential
of minus square root
of 2m E over h squared r.
That solves that equation.
You see, the solution
of these things
are either exponential
decays or exponential growths
and oscillatory solutions,
sines and cosines,
or E to the i things.
So here we have a decay,
because with energy less than 0,
the potential is 0.
So you're in a forbidden region,
so you must decay like that.
In this hydrogen
atom what happens
is that there's a power
of r multiplying here.
Like r to the n, or r to the
k or something like that.
If E is less than 0, you
have uE equal exponential
of plus minus ikr, where k
is square root of 2m E over h
squared.
And those, again,
solve that equation.
And they are sort of
wave solutions far away.
Now with this
information, the behavior
of the u's near the origin, the
behavior of the u's far away,
you can then make
qualitative plots
of how solutions would
look at the origin.
They grow up like r to the l.
Then it's a one
dimensional potential,
so they oscillate maybe, but
then decay exponentially.
And the kind of
thing you used to do
in 804 of plotting
how things look,
it's feasible at this stage.
So it's about time
to do examples.
I have three examples.
Given time, maybe
I'll get to two.
That's OK.
The last example is
kind of the cutest,
but maybe it's OK to
leave it for Monday.
So are there
questions about this
before we begin our examples?
Andrew?
AUDIENCE: What is consumption
of [INAUDIBLE] [? barrier ?]
dominates.
But why is that a
reasonable assumptions?
PROFESSOR: Well,
potentials that are just
too singular at the
origin are not common.
Just doesn't happen.
So mathematically
you could try them,
but I actually don't
know of useful examples
if a potential is very
singular at the origin.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] in
the potential [INAUDIBLE]
the centrifugal barrier.
That [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
An effective potential, the
potential doesn't blow up--
your potential doesn't blow
up more than 1 over r squared
or something like that.
So we'll just take it like that.
OK, our first example
is the free particle.
You would say come on.
That's ridiculous.
Too simple.
But it's fairly non-trivial
in spherical coordinates.
And you say, well, so what.
Free particles, you say
what the momentum is.
You know the energy.
How do you label the states?
You label them by three momenta.
Or energy and direction.
So momentum
eigenstates, for example
But in spherical
coordinates, these will not
be momentum
eigenstates, and these
are interesting
because they allow
us to solve for more
complicated problems, in fact.
And they allow you to
understand scattering out
of central potential.
So these are actually
pretty important.
You can label these
things by three numbers.
p1, p2, p3.
Or energy and theta and phi,
the directions of the momenta.
What we're going to label
them are by energy l and m.
So you might say how do we
compare all these infinities,
but it somehow works out.
There's the same number of
states really in either way.
So what do we have?
It's a potential
that v is equal to 0.
So let's write the
differential equation.
v is equal to 0.
But not v effective.
So you have minus h squared
over 2m d second uEl
dr squared plus h
squared over 2m l times
l plus 1 over r
squared uEl equal EuEl.
This is actually
quite interesting.
As you will see, it's a bit
puzzling the first time.
Well, let's cancel
this h squared over 2m,
because they're
kind of annoying.
So we'll put d second uEl over
dr squared with a minus-- I'll
keep that minus-- plus l times
l plus 1 over r squared uEl.
And here I'll put k
squared times uEl.
And k squared is the
same k as before.
And E is positive because
you have a free particle.
E is positive.
And k squared is given by
this, 2m E over h squared.
So this is the equation
we have to solve.
And it's kind of interesting,
because on the one hand,
there is an energy on
the right hand side.
And then you would say, look,
it looks like this just typical
one dimensional
Schrodinger equation.
Therefore that
energy probably is
quantized because it shows
in the right hand side.
Why wouldn't it be quantized
if it just shows this way?
On the other hand, it
shouldn't be quantized.
So what is it about this
differential equation that
shows that the energy
never gets quantized?
Well, the fact is that
the energy in some sense
doesn't show up in this
differential equation.
You think it's here, but
it's not really there.
What does that mean?
It actually means
that you can define
a new variable rho
equal kr, scale r.
And basically chain rule
or your intuition, this k
goes down here.
k squared r squared k squared
r squared, it's all rho.
So chain rule or
changing variables
will turn this equation into
a minus d second uEl d rho
squared plus l times
l plus 1 rho squared
is equal to-- times uEl--
is equal to uEl here.
And the energy has
disappeared from the equation
by rescaling, a trivial
rescaling of coordinates.
That doesn't mean that
the energy is not there.
It is there, because
you will find solutions
that depend on rho,
and then you will
put rho equal kr and
the energies there.
But there's no
quantization of energy,
because the energy doesn't
show in this equation anymore.
It's kind of a neat thing, or
rather conceptually interesting
thing that energy is
not there anymore.
And then you look at this
differential equation,
and you realize that
it's a nasty one.
So this equation is
quite easy without this.
It's a power solution.
It's quite easy without this,
it's exponentials are this.
But whenever you have a
differential equation that
has two derivatives,
a term with 1
over x squared
times the function,
and a term with 1
you're in Bessel territory.
All these functions
have Bessel things.
And then you have another
term like 1 over x d dx.
That is not a problem, but the
presence of these two things,
one with 1 over x squared
and one with this,
complicates this equation.
So Bessel, without
this, would be
exponential solution without
this would be powers.
In the end, the fact is that
this is spherical Bessel,
and it's a little complicated.
Not terribly complicated.
The solutions are
spherical Bessel functions,
which are not all that bad.
And let me say what they are.
So what are the
solutions to this thing?
In fact, the solutions
that are easier to find
is that the uEl's are r
times the Bessel function
jl is called spherical
Bessel functions.
So it's not capital
j that people
use for the normal
Bessel, but lower case l.
Of kr.
As you know, you solve this,
and the solutions for this
would be of the
form rho jl for rho.
But rho is kr, so we don't
care about the constant,
because this is a
homogeneous linear equation.
So some number here.
You could put a
constant if you wish.
But that's the solution.
Therefore your
complete solutions
is like the psi's of
Elm would be u divided
by r, which is jl of kr
times Ylm's of theta phi.
These are the
complete solutions.
This is a second order
differential equation.
Therefore it has to
have two solutions.
And this is what is called a
regular solution at the origin.
The Bessel functions
come in j and n type.
And the n type is
singular at the origins,
so we won't care about it.
So what do we get from here?
Well, some behavior
that is well known.
Rho jl of rho behaves like
rho to the l plus 2 over 2l
plus 1 double factorial
as rho goes to 0.
So that's a fact about
these Bessel functions.
They behave that
way, which is good,
because rho jl
behaves like that,
so u behaves like r
to the l plus 1, which
is what we derived
a little time ago.
So this behavior of
the Bessel function
is indeed consistent
with our solution.
Moreover, there's another
behavior that is interesting.
This Bessel
function, by the time
it's written like
that, when you go
far off to infinity
jl of rho, it
behaves like sine of
rho minus l pi over 2.
This is as rho goes to infinity.
So as rho goes to
infinity, this is
behaving like a
trigonometric function.
It's consistent with this,
because rho-- this is rho jl
is what we call u essentially.
So u behaves like this
with rho equal kr.
And that's consistent.
This superposition of
a sine and a cosine.
But it's kind of interesting
though that this l pi over 2
shows up here.
You see the fact
that this function
has to vanish at the origin.
It vanishes at the origin
and begins to vary.
And by the time you go
far away, you contract.
And the way it
behaves is this way.
The face is determined.
So that actually gives
a lot of opportunity
to physicists because
the free particle--
so for the free
particle, uEl behaves
like sine of kr minus l pi
over 2 as r goes to infinity.
So from that people have
asked the following question.
What if you have a
potential that, for example
for simplicity, a potential
that is localized.
Well, if this
potential is localized,
the solution far
away is supposed
to be a superposition
of sines and cosines.
So if there is no
potential, the solution
is supposed to be this.
Now another superposition
of sines and cosines,
at the end of the
day, can always
be written as some sine of
this thing plus a change
in this phase So in
general, uEl will
go like sine of kr minus l pi
over 2 plus a shift, a phase
shift, delta l that can
depend on the energy.
So if you haven't tried to
find the radial solutions
of a problem with
some potential,
if the potential is 0,
there's no such term.
But if the potential is
here, it will have an effect
and will give you a phase shift.
So if you're doing particle
scattering experiments,
you're sending
waves from far away
and you just see how the
wave behaves far away,
you do have measurement
information on this phase
shift.
And from this phase shift,
you can learn something
about the potential.
So this is how this
problem of free particle
suddenly becomes very
important and very interesting.
For example, as a way
through the behavior at
infinity learning something
about the potential.
For example, if the
potential is attractive,
it pulls the wave function
in and produces some sign
of delta that the corresponds
to a positive delta.
If the potential
is repulsive, it
pushes the wave
function out, repels it
and produces a delta
that is negative.
You can track those
signs thinking carefully.
But the potentials will teach
you something about delta.
The other case that this is
interesting-- I will just
introduce it and stop, because
we might as well stop--
is a very important case.
The square well.
Well, we've studied
in one dimension
the infinite square well.
That's one potential that
you now how to solve,
and sines and
cosines is very easy.
Now imagine a
spherical square well,
which is some sort of cavity
in which a particle is
free to move here, but
the potential becomes
infinite at the boundary.
It's a hollow sphere,
so the potential v of r
is equal to 0 for r less than a.
And it's infinity
for r greater than a.
So it's like a bag, a
balloon with solid walls
impossible to penetrate.
So this is the most
symmetric simple potential
you could imagine in the world.
And we're going to solve it.
How can we solve this?
Well, we did 2/3 of the
work already in solving it.
Why?
Because inside here
the potential is 0,
so the particle is free.
So inside here the solutions
are of the form uEl
go like rjl of kr.
And the only thing you will need
is that they vanish at the end.
So you will fix
this by demanding
that ka is a number z such--
well, the jl of ka will be 0.
So that the wave
function vanishes
at this point where the
potential becomes infinite.
So you've solved
most of the problem.
And we'll discuss it in detail,
because it's an important one.
But this is the most symmetric
potential, you may think.
This potential is very
symmetric, very pretty,
but nothing to write home about.
If you tried to
look-- and we're going
to calculate this diagram.
You would say well
it's so symmetric
that something pretty
is going to happen here.
Nothing happens.
These states will show up.
And these ones will show
up, and no state ever
will match another one.
There's no pattern, or
rhyme, or reason for it.
On the other hand,
if you would have
taken a potential v of r
of the form beta r squared,
that potential will
exhibit enormous amounts
of degeneracies all over.
And we will have to
understand why that happens.
So we'll see you next Monday.
Enjoy your break.
Homework will only happen
late after Thanksgiving.
And just have a great time.
Thank you for coming today,
and will see you soon.
[APPLAUSE]